re arrival
こんにちは
大阪人の石塔達也と申します
宜しくお願いします私は日本初最大級の食品ロス削減
フード車輪プラットフォームをやっております
おそらく日本で一番食品ロスを削減している
お供です
最近食品ロスという言葉がビッグワードがされてよく耳にするかと思いますが
職員の数について詳しくはなくてもいいけど初耳だっていうこといらっしゃいますか
いらっしゃいませやりやすいです
あの速品の数はでは1年間に日本短国でどれくらいの量が配されていうかわかる
でしょうか
6403万トンと言われていまして
すごい多そうなんですが8
食品ロスを削減するために友達と
もしくは職場の仲間とご飯を食べに行った後に
残飯ならないと思って食べていると私でで1本なんです
つまりは6430万人の私が毎年配布されています
という n 料これ日本韓国で本当に毎年のことなんです
で一方世界に目を向けてみると8億2100万人の人が飢餓に苦しんでます
政府の発表にいれば6人の一人の人が
子どもたちですねろくにご飯も食べてないん
いうような状況にある
これは市場に問題です
で a
私がですねなぜその食品ロスなるものを描い始めたかというと
a
こういうことです
コンテナでの廃棄何かというとですね私大学でまして
1998年から2000年にかけて
中華殉教角に勤務しております
今から20年から20年万円
世界の工場だとやって今メイリンちゃん多いですが
世界の消費地から
の以前には生産地だということで当然村工賃が安いから
世界からいろんなものが中国で作られていました
で
そこでですね工業製品にとって帰ると日本はすごい緻密で精度が高く
指示1章通りにもが上がってくるものをよするんですが
一方食品はコンビニのレジ前にあるようなチキンとか
きちっとした資格の
グラムが来てと行かないと全部アウトなんです
というのがコンテナ単位で配されている
居酒屋へのシシャモなんかでも
ロシアから引っ張っていましたなんかには悪阻も入ってるんですね
ただきざきたような女には困っちゃうんですこの超サンプル引いて
日買ったつもりがそれっていうのもこの辺フィート3乾いうとは違うということで入る
ですって言うほどを死ぬほど子見て議論が出そうになるほど見ました
というのが一つ
もう一つが
先ほど3.11の反射ありましたがって
本日は1.1なんです
nasa に1995年約20年前
阪神淡路大震災ました私も人たちました
私は大阪らのという仲というところ出身で
震度6巨
あらゆる物が倒れ床はガラス
まみで親父が本田の下敷きになってそれでもセーフでした余震は続いています
で数時間後に出てきた映像これ
ヤバイと思って気がついたらバックパックに水を背負って頭の方に少年野球の監督とか
大分友達とか
当時系たまで持ってなかったすけ入ったところで
1日に活動して帰って来て思ったことが一人でできることの限界と
それが無力感があって
ソルそして数ヶ月後には社会に調査に入るわけなんですが大人になったら社会人になっ
たらいわゆるとプラットフォームとか
さあソリューションみたいなを手がけたいな
いうふうに思ってそれが相まって今の食品ロスなるものをやっています
でその風シャーリングブラッドフォームなるものっていうのは単に安いだけではなくて
ですね
グランドイメージと桜
いわゆる市場価格を崩したくない b かあさんが生みの親のようにだ仕方なく
捨てている
ということを逆手にとりまして
そこに新しい価値まさに今で言うところの sd 地圖
私がこのサービスを始めたというのは2015年の2月病にしました
でその7カ月後に国連が sd 増された来たので sd スよりも
派兵のところでもあります
ねそんなこんなですねあの新しい
簡単に言うとお得にお買い物できるんですが
社会支援金額を含んでいて3%から5%
環境保護ですとか人道支援とか災害対策とか
全方動物こうっていうところに寄付をさせて頂い
損切る方を整理する千万を突破してい
継続が痴漢という
でそんな中でさらに見えてきた問題というのが日本は本当に有事の国であり震災
台風いっぱいあります
2,000円工藤つい坂根んですね
作面倒には台風1559号一般てありました
ザクッと100億ぐらいの三分の一がになりました
並び低年齢に南房の方で伊勢海老とか
アミィとかが
酸欠死しています
うちのフード付舎利蔵とが助けると思うんですが
2040年沼津 sdg のゴールは2030年度までに半減さそうというところに
邁進して今メンバーを募っているというかみんなにメッセージを届けて一緒になくして
いこうと食品ロスなるものは誰も特許する人はいないです
ん
企業はコスト削減に減らすことになりますし
消費者過程がからのロスっていうのも半分でています
約300万トンです当然その廃墟をするにあたって税金を投入されますし廃棄されると
co2が黙々とたくさん出ています
焼却されたものというのは目立てをしないといけない
環境問題にもありますし日本の自給率は37%その100-37というのが世界から
いうされています
世界には自動ロンドンも大都会道路含んでいると言う
誰も得しないものをもったいないを徒にしてつなげているということと
少子高齢化というのが叫ばれて久しいですが
2040年度約1800地方自治体
市区町村が自活できないが故に
別防止ていきます
そこにいろんなば税金が投入されるんですが学生さんの若い力未来がある
ただ内のお金でそれをその私たちのその基金として募って学生たん達に収穫のでした
今後増えてくるのは人手不足による3収穫無残なるものがいっぱい出てきます
それを減らしています
そしてこれらの南ため
ていう種子島なんですけれども前町長ですね
お手伝いありがとうということと学生たちのあの
まあ
みんなのためになったことが結果自分ためになりました勉強になりますというのお言葉
をいただきました
本当にその自分のための桜
動くよりも人のためになるという方が実は
モチベーションというか幅そこ時間
始めのバカ時間みたいなが出てくるんじゃないかなというふうに思いまして
その原体験も含めてこういうその社会事業みたいな事をビジネスの力を持って
サステイナブルにやろう
いうふうに思って動いているんですけど
まさにあの人のためにゴミ拾いを毎日して遅刻しましたぜはちょっと問題なので自分の
ための
を自分のためのお買い物が結果人のためにもなるというようなプラットフォームだり
なんだりを今後も生み出していきたいと思っています
そしてですね私たちはこれを応募とじゃなく
1.5次流通革命だと思っています
すでに昨年度の ec 脳底のプレイヤーさんがいるママです
でそこで流通された食品というのは2兆円ことです
も立派なプローバー一時ルートですねでその
いわゆるさんある
のなかの一つのビッグプレーヤーまくりまーピオされているところ自分には価値が
なくなったけどあなたにはあるかもねと
自分のその米機に正職員のみならずですけどベビーカーは要らなくなったけど
人にもありますよねでただその
ハイティ市場特に食品というのはそこのトレーサビリティ省の絶対的な安全が担保され
ないと流通しようがない
たとえばここにいる今日はの
私たちのサービスから提供されさせていただいたものもあるんですが知り合いなんて
どうですか
をまじる食べてくださいありがとうっていう話ですけど街中歩いて僕が後ろが飛んで
満了と被ってたら
高
強すぎるといるような話だと思います
ねっいうことをきちっとその廃棄されたもの3
新しい価値それが
sd ずのようなもしくは上場企業さんであれば
esg 投資的なの価値をくっつけて
マーケットインするでこれこそがもったいなの課税だと思って
それを1.5次流通革命だと捉えています
a
昨年度ぐらいからですかね
日経さんが一生懸命3ずだということも言われていますけど
取材を受ける度に今年ぐらいからですかね
一辺50流通匠みたいなことをちょっと世の中に出てい
イメージとしてはあの食品の設定別に業界マークて待ってないんです
レイヤーがすみません
ただ今年なし lan 内にぐらいにはという経済3画像いうそのバックをつくって
くるのかなのみたいなところがいろんな企業と連携して
そのフードロスなるもの作品改善していきたいなというふうに思っています
で私は
ジャン始まります
半年切ったんですかね東京オリンピックパラリンピックが始まります
先ほど申し上げたように世界には8億2100万人とが飢餓に苦しんでいる所の国から
も
選手団がきます
総理大臣は言います美しいやその通りだと思います
左脳先ほど私もありましたけど
日本が世界に誇る目誇れるものが生真面目3乾真面目さ
だからがゆえにちょっとした後さ
曲がった9位に神アウトってやってますけどそれをその
野菜を立派な選手ピンなるものを買ってに何だろうどうですか
形の例が out っておかしくないですか
味が同じあればものであればあの
いわゆる今までその行動成長期作っていた流通も否定するわけではないんです
3そこでありながら弾かれたものがちっとそれを求める
お得にお買い物をしてさせれば時代になっていくようなことを求める方も多く
いらっしゃいます
私たちの海は今8万人を超えてきました全国にこれ加速と的に
フィアして言って皆
でなく数笑顔なぁ組にしたいなと思っています
皆さんの明るし表情を見ていると非常に本当に日本語を捨てたもんではないなと思い
ます
f もそうですし2030年度までに今の食品廃棄を半減さそうという風に
入っています
それって
ものすごい量なんですが
ただそのまあ1.1なんだったり
3点ち子だったりその溝のことが起こってもきちっと整列できる
で残っているものにもうちょっと意識を受けて執刀しなきゃ位
あの子供たちの未来をちゃんと私たちがその環境も含めて守っていくんだというような
気があればその牛乳や卵や今日は数食べるかなーみたいなもんってあんまりそんなを
ひっくり返しておくからとらんどえんジャンパ
みたいなっていうのをやっていければなというふうに思います
で私たちのビジネス的にはですね今のその今まで配置されたものっていうのマーケット
にすることによって賞味期限が残りが3分の正位置というか1か月3週間2週間なって
いた時に行く to pick だが適正だったというカラーシミュレーターが止まっ
ています
これはまさに今後エーアイアールビッグのビッグデータの
声がかかって
桜井勢に戻していければなーみたいなことも考えている
すごく簡単に言うととある牛乳が200円だと思うが
keynote おとついの正味金であれば10演説ではなかったらそれを2000
熟成ということもできる
っていうことを非常に真面目に考えて
いるので皆さんと明るい未来をつくっていければと思っています
あとですね
先ほどちょっとあの台風みたいな話ししましたけど
あのフードシャレールのマッチングプラットフォームではウンス電マ汁なるもの可能な
んですね
あとその今防衛大臣が盛んに待ってローリングストップというお話もあります
今までは5年7年の鬼畜水とか
甲板のようなものを保存しておいて
の子に1年を聞いたところでリフレッシュさせればっていうことで
大会てました当然これは即ロスになります
これはその東京都民のみならず全国の1000反米狩り自治体でも備えてますし
皆さんの爪の企業でもそういうことがあったりすると思うんですが
その
1月分を
10%ぐらいおっ
ちょっと買ってそれを順次回していくというのがロール幾徳という考え方
これも a 2 z できればロスないことになるということと
をちょっと授業から離れるんですがあの初見釣果がたなるものがあったときに
まあ3日間は
皆さんで
いき注意てねということとを
まあ速品ロスの概念いたのも今後ちょっと取るに捉えていければなというふうに思って
ますし
あの
いわゆるビート ed マーケットというかオフィスで共有するようなサービスを展開
していきます
いろいろやっていきますあの
まぁ今後
そのサービスにフレっていたことも多いと思いますし常にご利用いた是非ともいうかも
しれませんけど
大切なのはあのちっちゃな一歩でも踏み出して誰にもデメリットがありませんから
そこに皆さんが一つ動くことによって a これに
日本のみならず世界での食品ロスというまさに sdg ずいうと目標中に細く切ると
12.3というところに生まれているのでそれを
まあ世界にですねオリンピックが終わっ
終わった時というかまぁ世界が注目されますので
さすが日本一人当たり世界一番入りするのも日本です
その日本が日本語でもったいないというのベレー場所をとっている
また遺産の言葉があるようにですね今こそこれ本当の価値観にして世界半身をし
もったい名を削減しフードロスをなくして新しい
に未来の挿せばものにつなげるということを次のパリに持っていこうじゃないかという
ことで
日本だから取って以来ます日本がまだ
ん
もはやはさん
[拍手]